on enlève la partie n'enlève la graine
et sa part les pillages et après ça en
puissance des buteurs note abîmé des
carottes fatigué ou des centaines de
kilos de tomates à écouler l'été chaque
jour dans cette exploitation agricole on
bichonne les légumes aux gueules cassées
n'ouvre le retour du marché sont en a
besoin on met de côté dans une caisse on
enlève les graines à l'intérieur auront
pour faire la transformation en somme
une fois sélectionnés classer les
légumes sont emmenés ici dans cette
cuisine un laboratoire pour transformer
les légumes en soupes et sauces ces
carottes ont été récoltés il ya quelques
jours les invendus vont être valorisés
en velouté simplement une fondue
d'oignons les carottes qui sont cuites
et assemblé et on
on ajouté
uniquement l'huile d'olive pour la
fondue d'oignons saler poivrer ses taux
bien plus gérard michaud s'est lancé
dans l'aventuré avec eric son frère il y
a dix ans pour lutter contre le
gaspillage et se diversifier à l'époque
m des centaines de milliers d'euros sur
la table
c'était un sacré pari aujourd'hui la
transformation soupe est devenu un
succès pour preuve près d'une centaine
de producteurs de la région lui apporte
des légumes pour les transformer mais il
a fallu franchir le pas de la
diversification du paysage
je suis dit si sûr mais sur les terres
d'ici avec le l'histoire de ma famille
avec le savoir faire qu'elle en a acquis
et ça n'empêche pas d'évoluer puisque
c'est ce que j'ai toujours connu
aujourd'hui gérard michaud aimerait
agrandir sa cuisine pour passer de 50000
à 300 mille bouteilles en production par
an sucrine du berry velouté tomates
courgettes ou encore carottes panais la
raffinerie propose une quarantaine de
soupe et de sauce
de quoi satisfaire les papilles des
consommateurs engagés